For the first solution, we'll have negative 18 plus 24i. And for the second
solution, we'll have 28 plus 16i. Nice work, if you got those two correct. We
start by distributing the 6i to 4 and 3i. Next, we multiply to get 24i, and 18i
squared. We replace i squared with its value of negative 1. So, essentially 18i
squared becomes negative 18. Now we just flip the order of the real part and
the imaginary part to get negative 18 plus 24i. In the second problem, we
distribute positive 6 to 2 and to 4i. In the second distribution, we want to be
careful. We have negative 4i times 2 here, and negative 4i times positive 4i
here. We perform multiplication on each of our four terms to get 12 plus 24i
minus 8i minus 16i squared. We combine our like terms of positive 24i and
negative 8i to get positive 16i. Next, we want to replace this i squared with a
value of negative 1. So negative 16i squared becomes positive 16. Remember,
whenever we have an i squared term, the sign just changes, and we no longer
have the variable of i squared. This was also true over here. We had positive
18i squared, which turned into negative 18. Finally, we add our like terms of
12 and 16 to get 28 plus 16i, the final result. Nice work if you got at least
one of those correct.